we're talking with Scott and Georgia his
80 year old parents are on a fixed
income they're coming up $400 read every
month I summed the Financial Peace
University and they flunked he's and his
family are trying to get out of $200,000
in debt student loans and kids student
loans and so their own baby step to mom
and dad have been loaning and borrowing
and giving back and all this $500 back
and forth and that's how far we got in
the conversation okay is that a fair
summary of what you told me so far that
sounds accurate yes okay so what is
their income the income is exactly two
thousand nine hundred seventy-five
dollars a month okay and what is their
housing arrangement do they own their
home where they renting well they have a
fit how to reverse mortgage that's
paying them and that's included in the
twenty nine hundred or it's already run
out well it seems like they don't have
any income from they just don't need to
make a payment I don't think I had
enough equity when they entered it to
get anything it just prevented them from
having to pay anything okay so that
don't have a house payment or rent right
now because of the reverse mortgage on
okay right so where does the 2900 go
other than food and lights and water
okay there's one there's one payment
that they have every month that just
started in August that's three hundred
and fifty dollars a month their AC died
they live in Florida so they need AC but
an AC died it had to be replaced
that was about 6500 that they didn't
have so they entered at least to own
contract with a subprime lender and
that's now costing them three hundred
and fifty dollars a month that gets us
pretty close to balanced that's where my
dilemma comes in I could suspend maybe
step two for two months pay that off for
them completely and free of that 350 M
and then we could fine tune their budget
to get them balanced that's that's where
I'm having trouble I don't know if I
should pay it I feel like I should
what's your household income
mine is about 225 now I shouldn't take
it yeah my mine
it shouldn't take you two months but
close we're also cashflow into kids
through college right now okay all right
sandwich generation sandwich between
college kids and aging parents okay yeah
I would do that but the problem is I
hear between the lines and the
conversation that they're gonna go do
this crap again that's my biggest fear
because they failed SPU and they fail
FPU what do you do to fail Financial
Peace University well taking out a lease
to own contract with a subprime lender
seems like a bad idea
I agree with that that that's how they
failed or they are they doing a budget
and they living on a budget are they in
control or they just they say they are
we went through it last night with a
fine-tooth comb there are a few things
that they're not willing to give up my
mother it's a manicure once a month and
she's not willing to not do that there
are a few other things in their budget
that I told them they stopped right now
such as a consolidation loan on a bunch
of credit cards
I said don't don't bother look they'll
call you a lot but they won't come after
you they can't there's nothing they can
do so I free that up out of their budget
but there's not really a whole lot of
wiggle room outside of my mother's
manicure every month where does all the
2,900 go it's the big chunk yeah
the electric bill the HOA fees where
they live life insurance what do they
have lying no parents to pay for their
final costs what's that cost well I
don't know they were talking about also
going out and buying a prepaid burial
but I told them if they have life
insurance
there yeah but you don't know what the
monthly is on the life insurance I do my
father is paying 226 a month and my
mother is paying 53 dollars a month
cancel that he may have cash value in
that that may be a rip out of whole life
policy it's not a deterrent policy for
$50,000 he's got a lot of health
problems he took it out probably just
about five years ago yeah unless you
think he's got less than a year to live
I would cancel it okay
they don't need life insurance I would
rather you take care of the cost of
their burial if someone has to then them
continue to be in the red and the end so
you've got that you've got the income to
have some wiggle room here they just
have got to start making some adult-like
choices here on some of these things I
don't know what the manicure cost is
probably not that much it's not that big
a deal what's their house worth should
they sell it
well the question becomes where do they
go because they're not going to come
live with me yeah I think you go down
there and you sell a bunch of stuff and
try to I want I wonder if there's enough
junk around there to sell to almost get
that heat and air paid off with that I
don't know yet I'll have to evaluate it
when I see it but the question is should
i suspend my baby step two
yeah just pay it off yeah if you can get
them balanced and and it's sustainable
because they're willing to behave if
they're not gonna behave it's just gonna
be you're throwing good money after bad
now you're just being giving a drunk a
drink right and so you know Mom and Dad
this if I pay this off it comes with
rules and the rules are we're gonna go
over your budget every month and you're
gonna stick to your budget and you're
not going to do anything else you're
gonna cancel this life insurance and
yeah you give up the manicure just on
principle and if you're not willing to
do that you're on your own figure it out
but
the problem is you're not you're you're
you're really not helping them if you're
just assisting them in their delusion
right if they are sounds like they're
trying to meet you here they're willing
to go over their budget with you they're
not being obstinate but when you sit
down with them and you you just you know
we're in Florida are they Central
Florida
deliver please call the villages I mean
is that like near Orlando you mean about
an hour away yeah okay I'll tell you
what what are we gonna do I'm gonna put
you on hold Kelly's gonna pick up and
we're gonna assign a coach to you guys
at our cost we're gonna pay for it and
that we'll sit down with them and with
you and we'll have a third party help
you thump them and let's get let's get
let's get them lined up here and get
them I mean for their own good we just
want them to we want them to win and
they don't have dignity where they are
there haven't always called their son
asks for money you know and so I think a
third party coach can help you guys
let's get that life insurance cancelled
let's get this heating/air paid off with
your help and the sale of a bunch of
junk and let's get them on a budget and
get their attitude straightened out to
where they're gonna live on that budget
and under no circumstances are they
going to make any decisions without you
and the coach approving the decision
from this point forward they're going to
live on the straight and narrow if they
don't want to do all of that don't give
them any money because all you're doing
then is participating in giving a drunk
a drink you know and that's that's that
sounds harsh but it's just you know when
you are enabling someone you are not
helping them and and when you're when
you're participating in their insanity
you're not helping them and that's not
real love it's just not it's just
weakness on your part because you just
don't deal with it and you just go I'm
gonna throw some money at so I'll have
to deal with it and that's just that's
the coward's way and so it's not you're
not being strong and so I'm with you
it's it's very difficult and I'm also
gonna send you a copy of the book
boundaries which is really what you're
struggling with and I don't blame you
it's a hard these are hard choices the
great news is you have a great income
and you have an awakening in a
we're nassif or your family for your
kids even for your mom and dad and
you're gonna be able to do this you've
got the stuff to fix this you've got the
intellectual brain cells to pull this
off so hold on we're gonna send your
boundaries I'm gonna send you a coach
this is the Dave Ramsey show